ANNOUNCER: Open content is
provided under a creative
commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer High-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation, or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu .
PROFESSOR ERIC GRIMSON: Let's
recap where we were.
Last lecture, we talked about,
or started to talk about,
efficiency.
Orders of growth.
Complexity.
And I'll remind you, we saw a
set of algorithms, and part of
my goal was to get you
to begin to recognize
characteristics of algorithms
that map into
a particular class.
So what did we see?
We saw linear algorithms.
Typical characterization, not
all the time, but typical
characterization, is an
algorithm that reduces the size
of a problem by one, or
by some constant amount each
time, is typically an example
of a linear algorithm.
And we saw a couple of examples
of linear algorithms.
We also saw a logarithmic
algorithm. and we like log
algorithms, because they're
really fast. A typical
characteristic of a log
algorithm is a pro-- or sorry,
an algorithm where it reduces
the size of the problem by a
constant factor.
Obviously-- and that's a bad
way of saying it, I said
constant the previous time--
in the linear case, it's
subtract by certain amount.
In the log case, it's
divide by an amount.
Cut the problem in half.
Cut the problem in half again.
And that's a typical
characterization of a log algorithm.
We saw some quadratic
algorithms, typically those
are things with multiple nested
loops, or iterative or
recursive calls, where you're
doing, say, a linear amount of
time but you're doing it a
linear number of times, and so
it becomes quadratic, and you'll
see other polynomial
kinds of algorithms.
And finally, we saw an example
of an exponential algorithm,
those Towers of Hanoi.
We don't like exponential
algorithms, or at least you
shouldn't like them, because
they blow up quickly.
And we saw some examples
of that.
And unfortunately, some problems
are inherently
exponential, you're sort of
stuck with that, and then you
just have to try be as
clever as you can.
OK.
At the end of the lecture last
time, I also showed you an
example of binary search.
And I want to redo that in a
little more detail today,
because I felt like I did that
a little more quickly than I
wanted to, so, if you really got
binary search, fall asleep
for about ten minutes, just
don't snore, your neighbors
may not appreciate it, but
we're going to go over it
again, because it's a problem
and an idea that we're going
to come back to, and I really
want to make sure that I do
this in a way that makes
real good sense you.
Again.
Basic premise of binary search,
or at least we set it
up was, imagine I have a sorted
list of elements.
We get, in a second, to how
we're going to get them
sorted, and I want to know,
is a particular
element in that list..
And the basic idea of binary
search is to start with the
full range of the list,
pick the midpoint,
and test that point.
If it's the thing I'm looking
for, I'm golden.
If not, because the list is
sorted, I can use the
difference between what I'm
looking for and that midpoint
to decide, should I look in the
top half of the list, or
the bottom half of the list?
And I keep chopping it down.
And I want to show you a little
bit more detail of
that, so let's create a simple
little list here.
All right?
I don't care what's in there,
but just assume that's my
list. And just to remind you, on
your handout, and there it
is on the screen, I'm going to
bring it back up, there's the
little binary search
algorithm.
We're going to call
search, which just
calls binary search.
And you can look at it, and
let's in fact take a look at
it to see what it does.
We're going to call binary
search, it's going to take the
list to search and the element,
but it's also going
to say, here's the first part
of the list, and there's the
last part of the list,
and what does it
do inside that code?
Well, it checks to see,
is it bigger than two?
Are there more than two
elements there?
If there are less than two
elements there, I just check
one or both of those to
see if I'm looking
for the right thing.
Otherwise, what does that
code say to do?
It says find the midpoint, which
says, take the start,
which is pointing to that place
right there, take last
minus first, divide it by
2, and add it to start.
And that basically, somewhere
about here,
gives me the midpoint.
Now I look at that element.
Is it the thing I'm
looking for?
If I'm really lucky, it is.
If not, I look at the value of
that point here and the thing
I'm looking for.
And for sake of argument, let's
assume that the thing
I'm looking for is smaller
than the value here.
Here's what I do.
I change-- oops!
Let me do that this way--
I change last to here, and keep
first there, and I throw
away all of that.
All right?
That's just the those-- let me
use my pointer-- that's just
these two lines here.
I checked the value, and in
one case, I'm changing the
last to be mid minus 1, which is
the case I'm in here, and I
just call again.
All right?
I'm going to call exactly
the same thing.
Now, first is pointing here,
last is pointing there, again,
I check to see, are there more
than two things left?
There are, in this case.
So what do I do?
I find the midpoint by taking
last minus first, divide by 2,
and add to start.
Just for sake of argument, we'll
assume it's about there,
and I do the same thing.
Is this value what
I'm looking for?
Again, for sake of argument,
let's assume it's not.
Let's assume, for sake of
argument, the thing I'm
looking for is bigger
than this.
In that case, I'm going to throw
away all of this, I'm
going to hit that bottom
line of that code.
Ah.
What does that do?
It changes the call.
So in this case, first
now points
there, last points there.
And I cut around.
And again, notice
what I've done.
I've thrown away most of the
array-- most of the list, I
shouldn't say array-- most
of the list. All right?
So it cuts it down quickly
as we go along.
OK.
That's the basic idea
of binary search.
And let's just run a couple of
examples to remind you of what
happens if we do this.
So if I call, let's
[UNINTELLIGIBLE], let's set up
s to be, I don't know, some
big long list. OK.
And I'm going to look to see, is
a particular element inside
of that list, and again, I'll
remind you, that's just giving
me the integers from zero up
to 9999 something or other.
If I look for, say, minus 1,
you might go, gee, wait a
minute, if I was just doing
linear search, I would've
known right away that minus
one wasn't in this list,
because it's sorted
and it's smaller
than the first elements.
So this looks like it's doing
a little bit of extra work,
but you can see, if you look at
that, how it cuts it down
at each stage.
And I'll remind you, what I'm
printing out there is, first
and last, with the range I'm
looking over, and then just
how many times the
iteration called.
So in this case, it just keeps
chopping down from the back
end, which kind of makes
sense, all right?
But in a fixed number, in fact,
twenty-three calls, it
gets down to the point
of being able to say
whether it's there.
Let's go the other direction.
And yes, I guess I'd better say
s not 2, or we're going to
get an error here.
Again, in twenty-three checks.
In this case, it's cutting up
from the bottom end, which
makes sense because the thing
I'm looking for is always
bigger than the midpoint, and
then, I don't know, let's pick
something in between.
Somebody want-- ah, I keep doing
that-- somebody like to
give me a number?
I know you'd like to give
me other things, other
expression, somebody
give me a number.
Anybody?
No?
Sorry.
Thank you.
Good number.
OK, walks in very quickly.
OK?
And if you just look at the
numbers, you can see how it
cuts in from one side and then
the other side as it keeps
narrowing that range, until it
gets down to the place where
there are at most two things
left, and then it just has to
check those two to say whether
it's there or not.
Think about this compared
to a linear search.
All right?
A linear search, I start at the
beginning of the list and
walk all the way through it.
All right, if I'm lucky and it's
at the low end, I'll find
it pretty quickly.
If it's not, if it's at the
far end, I've got to go
forever, and you saw that last
time where this thing paused
for a little while
while it actually
searched a list this big.
OK.
So, what do I want you to
take away from this?
This idea of binary search
is going to be a
really powerful tool.
And it has this property,
again, of
chopping things into pieces.
So in fact, what does that
suggest about the order of
growth here?
What is the complexity of this?
Yeah.
Logarithmic.
Why?
STUDENT: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR ERIC GRIMSON: Yeah.
Thank you.
I mean, I know I sort of said
it to you, but you're right.
It's logarithmic, right?
It's got that property of,
it cuts things in half.
Here's another way to think
about why is this log.
Actually, let me ask a slightly
different question.
How do we know this
always stops?
I mean, I ran three trials
here, and it did.
But how would I reason about,
does this always stop?
Well let's see.
Where's the end test
on this thing?
The end test-- and I've got
the wrong glasses on-- but
it's up here, where I'm looking
to see, is last minus
first less than or equal to 2?
OK.
So, soon as I get down to a list
that has no more than two
elements in it, I'm done.
Notice that.
It's a less than or equal to.
What if I just tested to see
if it was only, say, one?
There was one element
in there.
Would that have worked?
I think it depends on
whether the list is
odd or even in length.
Actually, that's probably
not true.
With one, it'll probably always
get it down there, but
if I've made it just equal to
two, I might have lost.
So first of all, I've got to be
careful about the end test.
But the second thing is, OK, if
it stops whenever this is
less than two, am I convinced
that this will always halt?
And the answer is sure.
Because what do I do?
At each stage, no matter which
branch, here or here, I take,
I'm cutting down the length
of the list that I'm
searching in half.
All right?
So if I start off with a list
of length n, how many times
can I divide it by 2, until
I get to something no
more than two left?
Log times, right.?
Exactly as the gentleman said.
Oh, I'm sorry.
You're patiently waiting
for me to reward.
Or actually, maybe you're not.
Thank you.
OK.
So this is, in fact, log.
Now, having said that,
I actually snuck
something by you.
And I want to spend a
couple of minutes
again reinforcing that.
So if we look at that code,
and we were little more
careful about this, what
did we say to do?
We said look an-- sorry.
Count the number of primitive
operations in each step.
OK.
So if I look at this code,
first of all I'm calling
search, it just has one call,
so looks like search is
constant, except I
don't know what
happens inside of b search.
So I've got to look
at b search.
So let's see.
The first line, that
print thing, is
obviously constant, right?
Just take it as a constant
amount of operations But.
let's look at the next one here,
or is that second line?
OK.
If last minus first is greater
than or equal to 2-- sorry,
less than 2, then either
look at this thing or
look at that thing.
And that's where I said we've
got to be careful.
That's accessing an element of
a list. We have to make sure
that, in fact, that operation
is not linear.
So let me expand on that very
slightly, and again, we did
this last time but I want
to do one more time.
I have to be careful about how
I'm actually implementing a
list.
So, for example: in
this case, my list
is a bunch of integers.
And one of the things I could
take advantage of, is I'm only
going to need a finite
amount of space to
represent an integer.
So, for example, if I want to
allow for some fairly large
range of integers, I might say,
I need four memory cells
in a row to represent
an integer.
All right, if it's a zero, it's
going to be a whole bunch
of ones-- of zeroes, so one,
it may be a whole bunch of
zeroes in the first three and
then a one at the end of this
thing, but one of the way to
think about this list in
memory, is that I can decide in
constant time how to find
the i'th element of a list.
So in particular, here's where
the zero-th element of the
list starts, there's where the
first element starts, here's
where the third element starts,
these are just memory
cells in a row, and to find the
zero-th element, if start
is pointing to that memory
cell, it's just at start.
To find the first element,
because I know I need four
memory cells to represent an
integer, it's at start plus 4.
To get to the second element,
I know that that's-- you get
the idea-- at the start plus 2
times 4, and to get to the
k'th element, I know that I
want to take whatever the
start is which points to that
place in memory, take care,
multiply by 4, and that tells me
exactly where to go to find
that location.
This may sound like a nuance,
but it's important.
Why?
Because that's a constant
access, right?
To get any location in memory,
to get to any value of the
list, I simply have to say which
element do I want to
get, I know that these things
are stored in a particular
size, multiply that index by 4,
add it to start, and then
it's in a constant amount of
time I can go to that location
and get out the cell.
OK.
That works nicely if I know that
I have things stored in
constant size.
But what if I have
a list of lists?
What if I have a homogeneous
list, a list of integers and
strings and floats and lists and
lists of lists and lists
of lists of lists and all
that sort of cool stuff?
In that case, I've got to
be a lot more careful.
So in this case, one of the
standard ways to do this, is
to use what's called a linked
list. And I'm going to do it
in the following way.
Start again, we'll point to the
beginning of the list. But
now, because my elements are
going to take different
amounts of memory, I'm going
to do the following thing.
In the first spot, I'm going to
store something that says,
here's how far you
have to jump to
get to the next element.
And then, I'm going to use the
next sequence of things to
represent the first
element, or
the zero-th element,
if you like.
In this case I might
need five.
And then in the next spot, I'm
going to say how far you have
to jump to get to the
next element.
All right, followed by whatever
I need to represent
it, which might only
be a blank one.
And in the next spot, maybe I've
got a really long list,
and I'm going to say
how to jump to
get to the next element.
All right, this is actually
kind of nice.
This lets me have a way of
representing things that could
be arbitrary in size.
And some of these things
could be huge, if
they're themselves lists.
Here's the problem.
How do I get to the nth-- er,
the k'th element in the list,
in this case?
Well I have to go to the zero-th
element, and say OK,
gee, to get to the next
element, I've got
to jump this here.
And to get to the next element,
I've got to jump to
here, and to get to the next
element, I've got to jump to
here, until I get there.
And so, I get some power.
I get the ability to store
arbitrary things, but what
just happened to
my complexity?
How long does it take
me to find the
k'th element?
Linear.
Because I've got to walk
my way down it.
OK?
So in this case, you
have linear access.
Oh fudge knuckle.
Right?
If that was the case in that
code, then my complexity is no
longer log, because I need
linear access for each time
I've got to go to the list,
and it's going to be much
worse than that.
All right.
Now.
Some programming languages,
primarily Lisp, actually store
lists these ways.
You might say, why?
Well it turns out there's
some trade-offs to it.
It has some advantages in terms
of power of storing
things, it has some
disadvantages, primarily in
terms of access time.
Fortunately for you, Python
decided, or the investors of
Python decided, to store
this a different way.
And the different way is to say,
look, if I redraw this,
it's called a box and pointer
diagram, what we really have
for each element
is two things.
And I've actually just reversed
the order here.
We have a pointer to the
location in memory that
contains the actual value, which
itself might be a bunch
of pointers, and we have a
pointer to the actual-- sorry,
a pointer the value and we have
a pointer to the next
element in the list.
All right?
And one of the things we could
do if we look at that is, we
say, gee, we could reorganize
this in a pretty
straightforward way.
In particular, why don't we
just take all of the first
cells and stick them together?
Where now, my list is a list of
pointers, it's not a set of
values but it's actually a
pointer off to some other
piece of memory that
contains the value.
Why is this nice?
Well this is exactly like this.
All right?
It's now something that I can
search in constant time.
And that's what's going to
allow me to keep this
thing as being log.
OK.
With that in mind, let's go
back to where we were.
And where were we?
We started off talking about
binary search, and I suggested
that this was a log algorithm,
which it is, which is really
kind of nice.
Let's pull together what this
algorithm actually does.
If I generalize binary search,
here's what I'm going to stake
that this thing does.
It says one: pick
the midpoint.
Two: check to see if this is
the answer, if this is the
thing I'm looking for.
And then, three: if not, reduce
to a smaller problem,
and repeat.
OK, you're going, yeah, come on,
that makes obvious sense.
And it does.
But I want you to keep that
template in mind, because
we're going to come
back to that.
It's an example of a very common
tool that's going to be
really useful to us, not just
for doing search, but for
doing a whole range of problems.
That is, in essence,
the template the describes
a log style algorithm.
And we're going to
come back to it.
OK.
With that in mind though,
didn't I cheat?
I remind you, I know you're not
really listening to me,
but that's OK.
I reminded you at the beginning
of the lecture, I
said, let's assume we have
a sorted list, and then
let's go search it.
Where in the world
did that sorted list
come from?
What if I just get a list of
elements, what do I do?
Well let's see.
My fall back is, I could just
do linear search, walk down
the list one at a time, just
comparing those things.
OK.
So that's sort of my base.
But what if I wanted, you know,
how do I want to get to
that sorted list?
All right?
Now.
One of the questions, before we
get to doing the sorting,
is even to ask, what should I do
in a search case like that?
All right, so in particular,
does it make sense, if I'm
given an unsorted list,
to first sort it,
and then search it?
Or should I just use the
basically linear case?
All right?
So, here's the question.
Should we sort before
we search?
OK.
So let's see, if I'm going to
do this, how fast could we
sort a list?
Can we sort a list in
sublinear time?
Sublinear meaning, something
like log
less than linear time?
What do you think?
It's possible?
Any thoughts?
Don't you hate professors who
stand here waiting for you to
answer, even when
they have candy?
Does it make sense to think we
could do this in less than
linear time?
You know, it takes a little
bit of thinking.
What would it mean--
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE] do I see
a hand, way at the back,
yes please?
Thank you.
Man, you're going to really make
me work here, I have no
idea if I can get it that
far, ah, your friend
will help you out.
Thank you.
The gentleman has it
exactly right.
How could I possibly do it in
sublinear time, I've got to
look at least every
element once.
And that's the kind of instinct
I'd like you to get
into thinking about.
So the answer here is no.
OK.
Can we sort it in linear time?
Hmmm.
That one's not so obvious.
So let's think about
this for a second.
To sort a list in linear time,
would say, I have to look at
each element in the
list at most a
constant number of times.
It doesn't have to be
just once, right?
It could be two or three times.
Hmm.
Well, wait a minute.
If I want to sort a list, I'll
take one element, I've got to
look at probably a lot of the
other elements in the list in
order to decide where it goes.
And that suggests it's going
to depend on how
long the list is.
All right, so that's a weak
argument, but in fact, it's a
way of suggesting,
probably not.
All right.
So how fast could
I sort a list?
How fast can we sort it?
And we're going to come back to
this, probably next time if
I time this right, but the
answer is, we can do it in n
log n time.
We're going to come
back to that.
All right?
And I'm going to say-- sort of
set that stage here, so that--
It turns out that that's
probably about the best we can
do, or again ends at the
length of the list.
OK, so that's still comes
back to my question.
If I want to search a list,
should I sort it first and
then search it?
Hmmm.
OK, so let's do the
comparison.
I'm just going to take an
unsorted list and search it, I
could do it in linear
time, right?
One at a time.
Walk down the elements
until I find it.
That would be order n.
On the other hand, if I want
to sort it first, OK, if I
want to do sort and search, I
want to sort it, it's going to
take n log n time to sort it,
and having done that, then I
can search it in log n time.
Ah.
So which one's better?
Yeah.
Ah-ha.
Thank you.
Hold on to that thought for
second, I'm going to
come back to it.
That does not assume I'm running
a search it wants,
which one's better?
The unsorted, and you have
exactly the point I want to
get to-- how come all the guys,
sorry, all the people
answering questions are way,
way up in the back?
Wow. that's a Tim Wakefield
pitch right there, all right.
Thank you.
He has it exactly right.
OK?
Is this smaller than that?
No.
Now that's a slight lie.
Sorry, a slight misstatement,
OK?
I could run for office, couldn't
I, if I can do that
kind of talk.
It's a slight misstatement in
the sense that these should
really be orders of growth.
There are some constants in
there, it depends on the size,
but in general, n log n has
to be bigger than n.
So, as the gentleman back there
said, if I'm searching
it once, just use the
linear search.
On the other hand, am I likely
to only search a list once?
Probably not.
There are going to be multiple
elements I'm going to be
looking for, so that suggests
that in fact, I want to
amortize the cost.
And what does that say?
It says, let's assume
I want to do k
searches of a list. OK.
In the linear case, meaning in
the unsorted case, what's the
complexity of this?
k times n, right?
Order n to do the search, and
I've got to do it k times, so
this would be k times n.
In the [GARBLED PHRASE]
sort and search case,
what's my cost?
I've got to sort it, and we
said, and we'll come back to
that next time, that I can do
the sort in n log n, and then
what's the search
in this case?
Let's log n to do one search, I
want to do k of them, that's
k log n, ah-ha!
Now I'm in better
shape, right?
Especially for really large n or
for a lot of k, because now
in general, this is going
to be smaller than that.
So this is a place where
the amortized cost
actually helps me out.
And as the gentleman at the
back said, the question he
asked is right, it depends
on what I'm trying to do.
So when I do the analysis, I
want to think about what am I
doing here, am I capturing
all the pieces of it?
Here, the two variables that
matter are what's the length
of the list, and how many times
I'm going to search it?
So in this case, this one wins,
whereas in this case,
that one wins.
OK.
Having said that, let's look
at doing some sorts.
And I'm going to start with
a couple of dumb sorting
mechanisms. Actually, that's
the wrong way saying it,
they're simply brain-damaged,
they're not dumb, OK?
They are computationally
challenged, meaning, at the
time they were invented, they
were perfectly good sorting
algorithms, there are better
ones, we're going to see a
much better one next time
around, but this is a good way
to just start thinking about
how to do the algorithm, or
how to do the sort.
Blah, try again.
How to do this sort.
So the first one I want to talk
about it's what's called
selection sort.
And it's on your handout, and
I'm going to bring the code up
here, you can see it, it's
called cell sort, just for
selection sort.
And let's take a look
at what this does.
OK.
And in fact I think the easy
way to look at what this
does-- boy.
My jokes are that bad.
Wow--
All right.
I think the easiest way to look
at what this does, is
let's take a really
simple example--
I want to make sure I put
the right things out--
I've got a simple little
list of values there.
And if I look at this code, I'm
going to run over a loop,
you can see that there, i is
going to go from zero up to
the length minus 1, and I'm
going to keep track of a
couple of variables.
Min index, I think I
called it min val.
OK.
Let's simulate the code.
Let's see what it's
doing here.
All right, so we start off.
Initially i-- ah, let me do it
this way, i is going to point
there, and I want to make sure
I do it right, OK-- and min
index is going to point to the
value of i, which is there,
and min value is initially going
to have the value 1.
So we're simply catting a hold
of what's the first value
we've got there.
And then what do we do?
We start with j pointing here,
and we can see what this
loop's going to do, right? j
is just going to move up.
So it's going to look at the
rest of the list, walking
along, and what does it do?
It says, right.
If j is-- well it says until j
is at the less than the length
of l-- it says, if min value is
bigger than the thing I'm
looking at, I'm going to do
something, all right?
So let's walk this.
Min value is 1,.
Is 1 bigger than 8?
No.
I move j up.
Is 1 bigger than 3?
No.
1 bigger than 6?
1 bigger than 4?
No.
I get to the end of the loop,
and I actually do a little bit
of wasted motion there.
And the little bit of wasted
motion is, I take the value at
i, store it away temporarily,
take the value where min index
is pointing to, put it
back in there, and
then swap it around.
OK.
Having done that, let's move i
up to here. i is now pointing
at that thing.
Go through the second
round of the loop.
OK.
What does that say?
I'm going to change min index to
also point there n value is
8, j starts off here, and I
say, OK, is the thing I'm
looking at here smaller
than that?
Yes.
Ah-ha.
What does that say to do?
It says, gee, make min
index point to there,
min value be 3.
Change j.
Is 6 bigger than 3?
Yes.
Is 4 bigger than 3?
Get to the end.
And when I get to the
end, what do I do?
Well, you see, I say, take temp,
and store away what's
here, all right?
Which is that value, and then
take what min index is
pointing to, and stick it in
there, and finally, replace
that value.
OK.
Aren't you glad I'm
not a computer?
Slow as hell.
What's this thing doing?
It's walking along the list,
looking for the smallest thing
in the back end of the list,
keeping track of where it came
from, and swapping it
with that spot in
the list. All right?
So in the first case, I didn't
have to do any swaps because 1
was the smallest thing.
In the second case, I found in
the next smallest element and
moved here, taking what was
there and moving it on, in
this case I would swap the 4 and
the 8, and in next case I
wouldn't have to do anything.
Let's check it out.
I've written a little bit of a
test script here, so if we
test cell sort, and I've written
this so that it's
going to print out what
the list is at the end
of each round, OK.
Ah-ha.
Notice what-- where am
I, here-- notice what
happened in this case.
At the end of the first round,
I've got the smallest element
at the front.
At the end of the second round,
I've got the smallest
two elements at the front,
in fact I got all
of them sorted out.
And it actually runs through
the loop multiple times,
making sure that it's
in the right form.
Let's take another example.
OK.
Smallest element at the front.
Smallest two elements
at the front.
Smallest three elements
Smallest four elements at the
front, you get the idea.
Smallest five elements
at the front.
So this is a nice little
search-- sorry, a nice little
sort algorithm .
And in fact, it's relying on
something that we're going to
come back to, called
the loop invariant.
Actually, let me put it on this
board so you can see it.
The loop invariant what does
the loop invariant mean?
It says, here is a property that
is true of this structure
every time through the loop.
In the loop invariant here is
the following: the list is
split, into a prefix or a first
part, and a suffix, the
prefix is sorted, the suffix
is not, and basically, the
loop starts off with the prefix
being nothing and it
keeps increasing the size of the
prefix by 1 until it gets
through the entire list, at
which point there's nothing in
the suffix and entire
prefix is sorted.
OK?
So you can see that, it's just
walking through it, and in
fact if I look at a couple of
another-- another couple of
examples, it's been a
long day, again, you
can see that property.
You'll also notice that this
thing goes through the entire
list, even if the list
is sorted before it
gets partway through.
And that you might look at,
for example, that first
example, and say, man by this
stage it was already sorted,
yet it had to go through and
check that the third element
was in the right place, and then
the fourth and then the
fifth and then the six.
OK.
What order of growth?
What's complexity of this?
I've got to get rid
of this candy.
Anybody help me out?
What's the complexity of this?
Sorry, somebody at the back.
n squared.
Yeah, where n is what?
Yeah, and I can't even see
who's saying that.
Thank you.
Sorry, I've got the wrong
glasses on, but you're
absolutely right, and in case
the rest of you didn't hear
it, n squared.
How do I figure that out?
Well I'm looping down
the list, right?
I'm walking down the list. So
it's certainly at least linear
in the length of the list.
For each starting
point, what do I do?
I look at the rest of the list
to decide what's the element
to swap into the next place.
Now, you might say, well,
wait a minute.
As I keep moving down, that part
gets smaller, it's not
always the initial length of
the list, and you're right.
But if you do the sums, or if
you want to think of it this
way, if you think about this
more generally, it's always on
average at least the length of
the list. So I've got to do n
things n times.
So it's quadratic, in
terms of that sort.
OK.
That's one way to
do this sort.
Let's do another one.
The second one we're going to
do is called bubble sort.
All right?
And bubble sort is also
on your handout.
And you want to take the first
of these, let me-- sorry, for
a second let me uncomment
that, and let me
comment this out--
All right, you can see the code
for bubble sort there.
Let's just look at it for a
second, then we'll try some
examples, and then we'll
figure out what
it's actually doing.
So bubble sort, which
is right up here.
What's it going to do?
It's going to let j run over
the length of the list, all
right, so it's going to start
at some point to move down,
and then it's going to let i
run over range, that's just
one smaller, and what's
it doing there?
It's looking at successive
pairs, right?
It's looking at the i'th and the
i plus first element, and
it's saying, gee, if the i'th
element is bigger than the
i'th plus first element, what's
the next set of three
things doing?
Just swapping them, right?
I temporarily hold on to what's
in the i'th element so
I can move the i plus first one
in, and then replace that
with the i'th element.
OK.
What's this thing doing then,
in terms of sorting?
At the end of the first pass,
what could I say about the
result of this thing?
What's the last element
in the list look like?
I hate professors who do this.
Well, let's try it.
Let's try a little test. OK?
Test bubble sort-- especially if
I could type-- let's run it
on the first list. OK, let's
try it on another one.
Oops sorry.
Ah, I didn't want to do it this
time, I forgot to do the
following, bear with me.
I gave away my punchline.
Let's try it again.
Test bubble sort.
OK, there's the first run, I'm
going to take a different
list. Can you see
a pattern there?
Yeah.
STUDENT: The last cell in the
list is always going to
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR ERIC GRIMSON: Yeah.
Why?
You're right, but why?
STUDENT: [UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
PROFESSOR ERIC GRIMSON:
Exactly right.
Thank you.
The observation is, thank you,
on the first pass through, the
last element is the biggest
thing in the list. On the next
pass through, the next largest
element is at the second point
in
the list. OK?
Because what am I doing?
It's called bubble sort
because it's literally
bubbling along, right?
I'm walking along the list once,
taking two things, and
saying, make sure the
biggest one is next.
So wherever the largest element
started out in the
list, by the time I get through
it, it's at the end.
And then I go back and
I start again, and
I do the same thing.
OK.
The next largest element
has to end up in
the second last spot.
Et cetera.
All right, so it's called bubble
sort because it does
this bubbling up until
it gets there.
Now.
What's the order
of growth here?
What's the complexity?
I haven't talked to the side
of the room in a while,
actually I have. This gentleman
has helped me out.
Somebody else help me out.
What's the complexity here?
I must have the wrong glasses
on to see a hand.
No help.
Log?
Linear?
Exponential?
Quadratic?
Yeah.
Log.
It's a good think, but why
do you think it's log?
Ah-ha.
It's not a bad instinct, the
length is getting shorter each
time, but what's one of the
characteristics of a log algorithm?
It drops in half each time.
So this isn't--
OK.
And you're also close.
It's going to be linear,
but how many times do
I go through this?
All right, I've got to do one
pass to bubble the last
element to the end.
I've got to do another pass to
bubble the second last element
to the end.
I've got to do another pass.
Huh.
Sounds like a linear number of
times I've got to do-- oh
fudge knuckle.
A linear number of things,
quadratic.
Right?
OK.
So this is again an example,
this was quadratic, and this
one was quadratic.
And I have this, to write it
out, this is order the length
of the list squared, OK?
Just to make it clear
what we're
actually measuring there.
All
right.
Could we do better?
Sure.
And in fact, next time we're
going to show you that n log n
algorithm, but even with bubble
sort, we can do better.
In a particular, if I look at
those traces, I can certainly
see cases where, man, I already
had the list sorted
much earlier on, and yet I
kept going back to see if
there was anything else
to bubble up.
How would I keep
track of that?
Could I take advantage of that?
Sure.
Why don't I just keep track
on each pass through the
algorithm whether I have
done any swaps?
All right?
Because if I don't do any swaps
on a pass through the
algorithm, then it
says everything's
in the right order.
And so, in fact, the version
that I commented out-- which
is also in your handout and I'm
now going to uncomment,
let's get that one out, get rid
of this one-- notice the
only change.
I'm going to keep track of a
little variable called swap,
it's initially true, and as long
as it's true, I'm going
to keep going, but inside of the
loop I'm going to set it
to false, and only if I do a
swap will I set it to true.
This says, if I go through an
entire pass through the list
and nothing gets changed,
I'm done.
And in fact if I do that, and
try test bubble sort, well, in
the first case, looks the same.
Ah.
On the second case, I
spot it right away.
On the third case, it takes me
the same amount of time.
And the fourth case, when
I set it up, I'm done.
OK.
So what's the lesson here?
I can be a little more careful
about keeping track of what
goes on inside of that loop.
If I don't have any more work
to do, let me just stop.
All right.
Nonetheless, even with this
change, what's the order
growth for bubble sort?
Still quadratic, right?
I'm looking for the worst case
behavior, it's still
quadratic, it's quadratic in the
length of the list, so I'm
sort of stuck with that.
Now.
Let me ask you one last
question, and then
we'll wrap this up.
Which of these algorithms
is better?
Insertion sort or bubble sort?
STUDENT: Bubble.
PROFESSOR ERIC GRIMSON:
Bubble.
Bubble bubble toil
and trouble.
Who said bubble?
Why?
STUDENT: Well, the first
one was too inefficient
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] store and
compare each one, so
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR ERIC GRIMSON: It's
not a bad instinct.
Right.
So it-- so, your argument is,
bubble is better because it's
is essentially not doing all
these extra comparisons.
Another way of saying it is,
I can do this stop when
I don't need to.
All right?
OK.
Anybody have an opposing
opinion?
Wow, this sounds like a
presidential debate.
Sorry, I should reward you.
Thank you for that statement.
Anybody have an opposing
opinion?
Everybody's answering these
things and sitting
way up at the back.
Nice catch.
Yeah.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR ERIC GRIMSON: I
don't think so, right?
I think selection sort, I
still have to go through
multiple times, it was still
quadratic, OK, but I think
you're heading towards a
direction I want to get at, so
let me prime this
a little bit.
How many swaps do I do in
general in bubble sort,
compared to selection source?
God bless.
Oh, sorry, that wasn't a
sneeze, it was a two?
How many swaps do I
do in bubble sort?
A lot.
Right.
Potentially a lot because I'm
constantly doing that, that
says I'm running that inner loop
a whole bunch of times.
How many swaps do I do
in selection sort?
Once each time.
Right?
I only do one swap potentially,
it-- though not
one potentially, each
time at the end of
the loop I do a swap.
So this actually suggests again,
the orders of growth
are the same, but probably
selection sort is a more
efficient algorithm, because
I'm not doing that constant
amount of work every
time around.
And in fact, if you go look up,
you won't see bubble sort
used very much.
Most--
I shouldn't say most, many
computer scientists don't
think it should be taught,
because it's just so
inefficient.
I disagree, because it's a
clever idea, but it's still
something that we have
to keep track of.
All right.
We haven't gotten to our n log n
algorithm, we're going to do
that next time, but I want to
set the stage here by pulling
out one last piece.
OK.
Could we do better in
terms of sorting?
Again, remember what
our goal was.
If we could do sort, then we
saw, if we amortized the cost,
that searching is a lot more
efficient if we're searching a
sorted list.
How could we do better?
Let me set the stage.
I already said, back here, when
I used this board, that
this idea was really
important.
And that's because that is
a version of a divide and
conquer algorithm.
OK.
Binary search is perhaps the
simplest of the divide and
conquer algorithms, and
what does that mean?
It says, in order to solve a
problem, cut it down to a
smaller problem and try
and solve that one.
So to just preface what we're
going to do next time, what
would happen if I wanted to do
sort, and rather than in
sorting the entire list at once,
I broke it into pieces,
and sorted the pieces, and then
just figured out a very
efficient way to bring those two
pieces and merge them back
together again?
Where those pieces, I would do
the same thing with, I would
divide them up into smaller
chunks, and sort those.
Is that going to give me a
more efficient algorithm?
And if you come back
on Thursday,
we'll answer that question.